galactus was once a man named galen from
a universe that existed before this
present one he is now known as galactus
the devourer of worlds and one of the
most biggest and one of the most
powerful marvel characters ever he has
manatees of power beyond the gods of
asgard or any super powered mortal being
he is a cosmic entity and represents the
power of a previous universe within him
he is well known for consuming worlds
especially the ones with celestial seeds
within them when galactus is well fed he
is more powerful than most celestials
including issan the searcher and arusham
the judge and when going one on one or
even more powerful than going two of
them at a time
and but there are celestials that are
way more powerful than him too and these
are the four of them
the first is tiermuth the communicator
or also known as the dreaming celestial
the celestial already held a high rank
amongst all the others as he is the one
responsible for communicating the
findings and results of the celestial
works to the fulcrum but it's not just
that tiananmen also had fought irishim
the judge in the past over the latter's
bias judgment on the deviance he took
down the prime celestial and was only
stopped when all the other celestials
combined their power to stop him he was
then sealed inside the earth and
eventually when he awoke from that
slumber or as in the mcu they call it
the emergence the power of this being
radiated throughout the universe and
galactus who was far away felt it and
for once in his long life remembered
what it is to feel fear which tells us
that galactus knows teamwork is a
celestial more powerful than him
the next is exeter exeter appears to be
kind of a title a function or a model
among celestials as uber to the watcher
stated that if one exit died another one
would eventually take its place
exeter's purpose was to destroy the life
on worlds which failed the celestial's
death
exeter the exterminator first appeared
in thor issue 387 judgement day released
in 1988 and he is a celestial of
titanic's size large and tallest
mountains he is an immeasurably powerful
celestial he possesses cosmic powers far
superior to those of a common celestial
which in turn possesses cosmic powers
beyond measurement
exeter is 10 times stronger than a
common celestials and he dwarfs even the
well-fed galactus in terms of power
the one comparison that made this
possible is thor's god blast it was
enough to repel and chase away galactus
but in the case of exeter it bounced off
like shining a torch light into a mirror
the third one is the mad celestial and
what is that you may ask so once there
were four of these celestials and they
were sick they were stricken with
madness and went around destroying
realities galactus became involved
because he wanted to protect the earth
because of the galactus seed which is an
item of extraordinary power hidden on
earth that would satiate galactus's
hunger forever
four of these celestials appeared and
galactus who had already developed four
planets was ready for them and even
managed to kill one of them but they
combined into the overpowered mad
celestial galactus was defeated rather
easily by it he would have been killed
if not for franklin richards re-powering
him to take on the mad celestial
together so that is three celestials
already that are more powerful than
galactus but they have to combine to one
so we'll count that as one
and the last one is none other than the
one above all the one above all the
mysterious leader of the celestials is
rarely seen
only once when two american astronauts
three deviants and the eternal known as
the forgotten one once paid the creature
a visit about the celestial mothership
that was maybe one of the few times he
was seen when the forgotten one was
injured while defusing a deviant nuclear
reactor a weapon the entity rescued him
and sent him to olympia to warn the
eternals and gods not to meddle with
celestial judgment he easily teleported
thor away took care of the odin
destroyer and also the unimine with ease
and he might as well be the codex for
the celestial's race because he was
taken away by the queen of nevers when
all the other celestials were killed by
logos which means he holds enough power
and essence to be classified as above
all the celestials and maybe galactus as
well
so yeah that is all i have about the
celestials which are more powerful than
galactus and if there is another entry
then do share it with us in the comments
section below
so anyway with that we come to the end
of the video so do hit that like button
for support and click on that subscribe
button as well to be a part of the mind
q family but most of all smash that bell
icon for regular updates on new monster
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam